Let’s summarise some of the things we have
learned: in this lecture we talked about spatial
image processing operators.
These operations are where the output pixel
is a function of the corresponding surrounding
region in the input image.
We talked about edge effects and this where
the input window falls off the edge of the
input image and we need some sort of strategy
to deal with this particular problem.
We talked about convolution; this is where
we apply a matrix which we call a kernel to
an image using the convolution operator.
We can use this to perform a raft of really
useful image processing functions such as
smoothing and gradient calculation.
We looked at a number of standard kernels
such as the Gaussian, the derivative of the
Gaussian and the Laplacian of Gaussian.
We also looked at the correlation.
Correlation is similar to convolution; some
of the signs in the equation are changed and
it’s equivalent to convolution if the kernel
is symmetric.
Correlation is useful for tasks such as template
matching and we used this technique to find
the robot Bender in a very busy crowd scene.
We also discussed non-linear filters; we talked
about rank and median filters and showed how
they are useful for removing extreme noise.
We also talked about morphological image processing,
and this is a technique that allows us to
keep or remove blobs that are based on their
size and shape.
If you have an image with small noise blobs
you can use a morphological filter to simply
remove them.
Or if you have an image—perhaps the result
of thresholding, the object has got some small
holes in it that you are not happy about—you
can use a morphological processing to fill
those holes in.